c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soit il est bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir deuxième jour de la visite
d'Emmanuel Macron en Algérie un
programme chargé ce vendredi il a
commencé par un hommage au soldats morts
pour la France au cimetière français de
Saint-Eugène autre temps fort de la
journée une Rencontre avec des jeunes
entrepreneurs algériens retour sur cette
journée dans un instant en Angola le
MPLA parti au pouvoir à revendiquer sa
victoire aux élections présidentielles
et législatives après avoir été crédité
par la commission électorale de 51% des
suffrages le scrutin a été marqué par
une faible participation et un score
historique du parti d'opposition l'unité
son candidat à d'Alberto Costa junior
rejette la victoire de son rival on sera
à Luanda dans ce journal
ce soir nous recevons Alphonse Lawson
opposant togolais nous évoquons avec lui
les questions sécuritaires et la
contamination du djihadisme dans le
Golfe de Guinée le Togo est de plus en
plus touché par les attaques interview à
suivre
séquence solennelle ce matin au
cimetière français de sainte-eugène à
Alger le président français a déposé une
gerbe de fleurs pour rendre hommage au
soldats morts pour la France un hommage
côté chrétien du cimetière mais aussi
côté israélite il a ensuite rencontré
des jeunes entrepreneurs algériens et
dans des déclasses et déclarations il a
affirmé sa détermination à construire un
partenariat solide et durable Laurent
Berchet
regardez l'histoire en face et
reconnaître les erreurs du passé sans
pour autant s'en repentir c'est ainsi
qu'Emmanuel Macron a présenté vendredi
la création d'une commission chargée
d'étudier les dérives de la colonisation
en Algérie
on va mettre en place une vraie
commission mixte d'historienne et
d'historien on va ouvrir toutes nos
archives de part et d'autre on va lui
demander de travailler sur toute la
période du début de la colonisation
jusqu'à la fin de la guerre
en insistant sur le devoir de mémoire le
président français espère apaiser des
relations souvent tendues entre Paris et
Alger également au cœur des discussions
avec son homologue algérien l'épineuse
question des visas à l'origine de la
dernière brouille diplomatique entre les
deux pays le président français a ainsi
réitéré sa fermeté face à l'immigration
clandestine tout en annonçant une
ouverture de l'immigration choisie nous
avons déjà 30 000 étudiants algériens en
France chaque année nous en
accueillerons 8000 de plus cette année
ce qui est une chance pour nos pays et
donc ce que nous voulons c'est assumer
cette mobilité choisie et positive
étudiants des entrepreneurs des
responsables politiques des chercheurs
des acteurs culturels ou sportifs
en étant aussi plus rigoureux dans la
lutte contre l'immigration clandestine
après une visite à Oran où il doit
rencontrer des acteurs sportifs et
culturels Emmanuel Macron est de nouveau
attendu à Alger samedi en vue de signer
un accord de partenariat renouvelé avec
l'Algérie
en bref sachez que le Maroc a rappelé
son ambassadeur en Tunisie pour
consultation le royaume chérifien se dit
heurter par la décision du président
tunisien Kais d'inviter un sommet à
Tunis le leader indépendantiste du Front
Polisario
en Angola le parti au pouvoir le MPLA
l'emporte avec 51% des voix selon des
résultats officielles comptabilisés
comptabilisant pardon la quasi-totalité
des votes exprimées le président sortant
Joao Lorenzo et sur le point d'être
reconduit pour un nouveau mandat le
scrutin a été marqué par un faible taux
de participation et des accusations de
fraude les détails de notre envoyé
spécial à Luanda Clément bonne route
selon la Commission nationale électorale
angolaise les habitants de la capitale
Luanda ont voté massivement pour
l'opposition mercredi ici beaucoup sont
évidemment déçus que l'UNITA le parti
historique d'opposition n'est pas
remporté le scrutin mais ils estiment
néanmoins que cette élection marque un
tournant dans l'histoire du pays en même
temps ça a été fait je ne suis pas
satisfaite que nous ayons 90 députés je
voulais qu'on gagne dans tout le pays
en termes de compétition électorale le
MPLA n'a pas vraiment d'adversaire ce
que nous attendions c'était un petit
équilibre au Parlement et ça nous
l'avons eu
le MPLA enregistre une baisse dans la
capitale et si l'unité enregistre une
hausse ça veut dire que le peuple croit
en l'unité et pas dans le MPA ce qui
explique sa défaite ici à Luanda et cela
va les pousser à réfléchir pour la suite
pour le journaliste et militant
anticorruption Rafael Marquès ses
élections pourraient aussi être le début
d'une nouvelle ère dans la vie politique
angolaise après 47 ans de pouvoir sans
partage
non seulement le MPLA et le président
Joao Lorenzo vont devoir négocier avec
l'opposition ils devront aussi réformer
véritablement le gouvernement c'est la
fin du MPLA en tant que partie état et
si le MPLA dans les deux prochaines
années ne se renouvelle pas de façon
radicale c'est un parti qui court le
risque d'être oblitérer par la volonté
populaire
se maintient donc au pouvoir mais
réalise son score le plus faible depuis
la fin de la guerre civile en 2002 il y
a 5 ans en 2017 il avait obtenu plus de
61% des voix
et j'ajoute que le candidat de l'UNITA
d'elberto Costa Junior a rejeté ce
vendredi la victoire du MPLA il a
dénoncé des écarts entre les résultats
officiels et le décompte effectué par
son propre parti sur la base des PV
affichés devant chaque bureau de vote et
réclame un recomptage des voix par une
commission indépendante
le 22 août dernier une attaque jihadiste
à de nouveau frappé le nord du Togo
faisant un mort et 12 blessés depuis la
région des Savanes frontalières avec le
Burkina Faso a été placé sous état
d'urgence le Togo comme d'autres pays de
golfe du Golfe de Guinée sont menacés
par l'expansion du terrorisme islamiste
comment le pays se prépare-t-il à faire
face à cette menace nous aborderons
cette question ce soir avec notre invité
Alphonse Lawson opposant togolais et
président du Mouvement pour un Togo
nouveau bonsoir vous êtes également je
le rappelle coordinateur de la coalition
de la diasporatogolaise pour
l'alternance et la démocratie merci
d'être avec nous sur ce plateau je vous
en prie alors j'aimerais avant d'aborder
cette question que vous nous fassiez un
point sur la situation sécurité dans le
nord du pays
merci pour cette opportunité de parler
du Togo de parler de la situation
dramatique au nord du pays en effet le
nord du pays la région du savane qu'on
venait de le dire sinistré cette région
est sous les attaques des terroristes et
la population est laissée à elle-même
martyrisé et nous concitoyens sont tués
sont blessés et c'est un drame pour tous
les Togolais au Togo et dans la diaspora
et pour nous c'est une préoccupation
majeure de voir comment le Togo qui est
un pays sinistré depuis 1963 où il y a
un régime de dictatures de père en fils
qui sait monarchisé depuis 2005 qui a dû
blesse les Togolais et c'est une
situation dramatique pour les Togolais
donc la situation au nord du pays vient
s'ajouter à une situation qui dure
depuis 60 62 ans pratiquement
aujourd'hui nous comptons plus de 120
prisonniers dans les géoles de Faure
Gnassingbé ou parmi ces prisonniers là
il y a six qui sont tués
qui sont qui ont été exécutés tout
simplement et le Togo est terrorisé par
le régime de fantasymbé c'est ça la
situation dramatique du Togo aujourd'hui
alors pour en revenir donc vous évoquez
la situation politique
du Togo mais aussi on parle également de
la situation sécuritaire quels sont vos
propositions les autorités congolais
togolaises pardon ont réuni de nombreux
partis politiques pour leur demander
pour les écouter pour écouter leur
proposition pour lutter contre le
djihadisme qu'est-ce que vous vous
préconisez il faut d'abord d'entrer de
jeu dire que c'est une situation
dramatique et le régime de fantasyber
dans une démarche qui est une démarche
de panique dans la mesure où on remarque
que ce gouvernement a été incapable
d'assurer la sécurité des Togolais il y
a un an ils ont voté le Parlement
monocollant a voté une lune un budget à
colossal de programmation militaire des
milliards de France et on constate que
ce régime n'est pas en mesure
aujourd'hui d'assurer la sécurité alors
disons ils ont un poste avancer au nord
du pays depuis quelques années et vous
savez que le Togo c'est un régime
militaire et on ne comprend pas pourquoi
ce gouvernement est incapable
aujourd'hui d'assurer la sécurité alors
notre proposition si vous permettez et
bien on remarque complètement qui a une
carence que ce gouvernement est
incompétent pour assurer la sécurité et
en plus de cela et bien il y a je dirais
un ensemble d'éléments qui
qui martyrise la population la
population soumis à la fin à la misère
un manque d'assistance tout ça c'est un
terreau fertile alors justement les
autorités togolaises appellent la
population à coopérer avec l'armée pour
lutter contre le terrorisme est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est possible dans ces
contexte politique c'est très difficile
dans la mesure où le fondation B utilise
l'armée pour terroriser la population
pour tuer la population pour blesser
cette population là et donc l'armée et
c'est de maintenir un régime militaire
monarchique où toutes les élections sont
des élections frauduleuses depuis les
années 90 dans ces conditions-là et
c'est très difficile pour cette
population n'est-ce pas d'être aux côtés
de cette armée qui qui qui qui le tue
qui le qui le martyrise qui le met en
prison et comme je viens de vous le dire
nous avons plus de 120 togolais qui sont
à jetés dans les géoles de fantasyme
sans jugement voyez-vous et parmi
lesquels il y a une femme qui s'appelle
Leila tra et qui qui conduit libérer
immédiatement parce que c'est sa
condition de sa santé se dégrade votre
message votre message est passé
malheureusement nous n'avons pas plus de
temps à vous consacrer merci beaucoup
Alphonse là au sol donc je répète vous
êtes opposant togolais coordinateur de
la coalition de la diasporatogolaise
pour l'alternance et la démocratie merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je vous remercie on en vient
cet événement culturel au Cap en Afrique
du Sud fait il met un marché de
programme audiovisuel du continent c'est
la première fois que ce type d'événement
est organisé il réunit professionnel de
la musique de la télévision et du cinéma
le salon abrite aussi le Festival
international du film d'animation du cap
qui fait de sa deuxième année reportage
de Caroline Dumet Stéphane Kersten c'est
Nadine
les dessins animés Sud-Africains ont
levant aux poupées sont de plus en plus
demandés au pays de Walt Disney alors
pour fêter ses 10 ans le festival du
film d'animation du Cap s'est déroulé au
sein de Fame un marché réunissant
professionnel de la musique et du cinéma
une bonne idée selon ses jeunes
créatrices qui ont produit la
bande-annonce du
festivals est très mal compris beaucoup
de parents découragent leur enfant de
participer à des activités artistiques
car ils disent que cela ne paie pas mais
on oublie que tout ce que nous voyons
ici a débuté sur une feuille de papier
du coup quand les gens sortent de
l'école ils ne sont pas vraiment
préparés à l'industrie
pour permettre aux artistes de mieux
connaître l'industrie des personnalités
très inspirantes ont participé au salon
comme cette productrice kenyane
responsable des programmes africains
Netflix elle vient de créer des séries
en langue locale africaine
que vous soyez costumière écrivant ou
même producteur vous avez un rôle à
jouer en racontant nos histoires en
préservant nos cultures et on les
partageant avec le reste du monde je
pense vraiment que ceux qui racontent
les histoires ont un rôle crucial à
jouer
et ceux qui ont des choses à raconter
font la queue pour essayer de lui parler
les producteurs recherchent des
histoires africaines il s'intéresse de
plus en plus à l'Afrique francophone
c'est vrai que je n'ai pas de titre
original en français mais je peux vous
assurer que mes collègues et ceux qui
travaillent avec nous en coproduction
ratissent l'Afrique de l'Ouest
francophone pour nous trouver du contenu
80 stands 37 pays africains c'est un bon
début pour les organisateurs
que plus les producteurs auront des
opportunités de rencontrer des jeunes
talents et chacun de voir de quoi il est
capable mieux ce sera sur le long terme
pour tout le monde
[Musique]
ce premier salon multimédia aura vu
défiler plus de 2000 participants chacun
a promis d'y être présent l'année
prochaine
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'Afrique restez avec nous l'info
continue sur France 24
[Musique]